So Donald Trump went on a pardoning spree
yesterday and there are all sorts of different
cakes
and reports about this, what it means, how
he picked, who to pardon, but unfortunately
the most precise and narrow analysis is that
Donald Trump is doing three things here and
they're all bad.
Number one.
This is an example of elites pardoning elites,
plain and simple.
And this is also Donald Trump laying the groundwork
for future pardons of his own convicted associates.
This is also number three, an indirect attack
on James comi and Robert Mueller.
And we're going to go through each of these,
uh, in order Donald Trump yesterday.
Pardon?
People ranging skin color ranging in political
party and it is all very much a sham.
Now, before we get into it, remember that
a pardon is a form of clemency.
A pardon is when a government official forgives
a certain criminal offense.
The offense, uh, can stay on the person's
criminal record.
The person is not subject to further restrictions
or criminal penalties that other convicts
or ex-convicts may be subjected to.
A pardon is a form of clemency.
Clemency is a general term for reducing the
penalty for a particular crime without clearing
the criminal record.
It could be a pardon, could be that a sentence
gets commuted, could be a reprieve, which
is you temporarily put off or suspend the
punishment, but don't cancel it all together.
In total.
Donald Trump granted 11 clemency, uh, instances
yesterday.
It includes Edward John DeBartolo, jr a former
real estate developer and NFL executive pled
guilty to sexual assault charges, Trump granting
him clemency rod Blagojevich, the corrupt
democratic governor of Illinois, former governor
accused of trying to sell a Senate seat, has
served eight years of a 14 year sentence for
those pay to play charges.
Trump is getting him out of prison.
Former New York police commissioner Bernie
Kerik convicted of tax fraud and lying to
officials, a Republican Bernie Kerik of course,
also connected to Donald Trump's personal
attorney, Rudy Giuliani, Mike Milken, an investment
banker known as the junk bond King convicted
of felony charges that included conspiracy
securities fraud, kind of the poster child
of 1980s financial scandals.
And, uh, Donald Trump has also a pardoned
former Bush administration official.
David Safavian, who was convicted, convicted
in connection with the Abraham off Jack Abraham
off corruption scandals.
So a lot of corruption here being pardoned.
Donald Trump said about rod Blagojevich.
It was a person, a prosecution by the same
people.
Comi Fitzpatrick, the same group.
Trump said, uh, ms stating by the way, the
Illinois us attorney's last name.
So first of all, there was this reaction of,
Oh wow, Trump pardoned a Democrat.
Rod Blagojevich remember this was the pardon
of [inaudible] was a way to attack James comi.
It was elites pardoning elites more than anything
else.
It was also Trump pardoning corruption and
corruption continuing to be normalized, which
is one of the themes of these, uh, clemency
grants.
And um, then you also saw, you know, Trump
pardoning some white people and some black
people.
It's irrelevant.
We are again, talking about elites here and
what this functions as is a pretext for future
pardons of Trump associates to be able to
say, when Trump ultimately pardons stone Michael
Flint, you know, we don't know who yet.
Trump will be able to say, listen, I've been
doing this all along.
I find people who were railroaded and I pardoned
them.
It includes people of all skin colors.
It includes members of multiple political
parties.
That's all this is.
It is a lot of corruption related charges
being pardoned.
Trump arguably the most corrupt president
in the modern era.
It's a sham and I would be shocked if at minimum
Trump doesn't end up pardoning Roger Stone
no matter what sentence Roger Stone ultimately
gets.
And it may be much shorter than what was initially
recommended by prosecutors.
As you know, um, I don't know if Trump will
ultimately partner, pardon his former national
security advisor, Michael Flynn.
Uh, Michael Cohen, Trump's old personal lawyer
I think is less likely for a pardon after
what has been said publicly between the two.
But this is a message from Donald Trump.
If you do things I don't like to Roger Stone
and Michael Flynn or whoever, I will just
pardon them and he will.
This is also the forced normalization of not
just political corruption but also of other
crimes.
And you are going to hear, you know, blood
Goya Vich got a rod deal, political corruption,
that's not really a crime.
You will hear, I've pardoned Democrats and
Republicans alike.
And of course you have to step back and see
the bigger narrative.
This is elites protecting elites.
This is the rich protecting the rich and it
is all a shell game.
And with rod Blagojevich as the specific example,
and I want to talk about this next.
This also appears to be very much related
to some appearances that rod Blagojevich,
his wife had on TV, badmouthing the people
that were investigating Donald Trump.
Let's
talk about
that next.